pull up
[Music]
um
his feet are going to be like that it's
going to be easy
uh
[Music]
okay okay so here's just a variation
i i put it on my body
and then the next thing we're doing is
understand how balance works
okay when he gets this stance here
this asymmetrical then i can step
in this place
i can't go whenever
there
oh just getting used to what that feels
like
there then you can come in
so you you're not ever making this
mistake
she's gonna have a big face even though
you think she cocky's there it's not
there
move the foot back one no other one
here it is
oh two drills at once you basically
[Applause]
okay so the problem with forms
training is that when you go to giwaza
you try to do the form as if it's a
pre-programmed solution to what you're
facing
that's the wrong way to think about the
art what you want to do instead
is actually understand why the technique
works
and then you make sure those elements
are in
whatever you're trying to do okay so for
example
uh you're just gonna do the move you
have a tank
you come around here and then you have
this step all right
but a certain thing has to be in place
for that to work
you can't just you can't just do the
form as if you're doing it in the air
and then it'll work okay so as i'm going
around here
i can't go like this but that outside
leg is in front
of this leg he doesn't have the same
uh weakness
yes it's about outward kazushi but it's
not a plug and play thing
you have to make sure that all of its
aspects
are in place so this we're out of line
there it is and then i can come in
then the leg is light
so i'm not plug and play i'm present
oh there it is
blood i can play
i'm paying attention paying attention
paying attention boom there it is
okay no more plug and play go so we're
going to use the same
understanding principle there he goes
whoa there it is
there it is
there it is okay
say same beginning now we're going to
use this principle more so
if i stop here that's why i had to do it
but
one for example uh so what i want
is this foot go ahead and move move
move it more yes that's what i'm looking
for
okay go backward okay but if i
change my angle i have it
same thing this this foot
from this line this foot is behind this
foot
you see you get it okay so i can start
moving myself
so that i always end up
in that angle you see that and i don't
have to
go here and then move you
i'm moving myself
i'll find the vector that i need
to get it if i move over here it'll work
we'll work here
okay let's go you're trying to learn
what makes
that chica spread your feet up okay
so i need his weight distribution
such that this foot is further back go
ahead and do it for me
you see behind that then this shikaku
works
okay if if the other leg is
forward then that chicago does not work
okay a lot of times we just force
somebody but
it's not the same now
in the first drill you you went ahead
and you manually
[Music]
the leg okay
now the point to realize is when he
opens his feet can just stand like that
it's if i stand from this
his angle are even but if i enter from
this angle from
this angle that foot is behind this foot
you see so from this angle this is very
heavy
but from this angle this foot is very
long
okay and so what happens when you do
your plug and play
let's say you're you're going to do
tenshi nagi right and you go like this
and the guy
is really strong and you're like whoa
what happened
is that supposed to work and it's
because you're not
you're not setting up the angle
or you're entering an angle that you
you're not
actually going to be able to do it so i
could take this
same straight thing in terms of my
body but if i enter from this
part now now it all happens
so i want to understand the principle so
we're just
i could do it mechanically but it's
there
okay good legacy or
i can just play with what i'm doing
what's that and find that angle
again don't throw yourself you'll either
be tripped or not
so that that foot is always going to be
behind so put it put it uh in front
you see if i enter here it's heavy
but if i enter here it will be light
okay it'll be light
and this ability to understand the art
and principles
will free me from plug and play and
allow
all the micro adaptations i need when
he's not just taking my falls for me
okay
so we've just stepped out of kiwan
and we're going to see if shikaku is
actually
active because if it is the front leg
will be lightened
which will allow me to sweep it
do you get it it's just a test so
i'm doing the movement right
[Music]
there's that one
parallel go ahead
this leg is heavy
you can't do it okay i have to change
now this fits behind foot right okay
try it we'll do katana notice okay so i
have to
look for it there it is then it will
work
so with my uh kazushi with my uh tested
bhakti tyson bucky
i make that all happen but stop but if
i'm not aware of what's supposed to
happen
this is where you get weird things
so i have to make sure that it happens
[Music]
and setting it up
not just plug and play i'm looking for
that
i'm setting it up
versus having to pick him up
he's already off bounce okay so
boom then he's like
leg's gonna be right
[Music]
hey